اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نواصل معكم تغطيه لنزاع
المسلحه في السودان صراع الجنرال مستمر
ولا افق واضحه لنهايته حتى الان
[موسيقى]
سادس ايام المعارك والمواجهات في السودان
ايام مليئه بالرصاص والضحايا من مدنيين
وعسكريين اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء
السودان كشفت عن ارتفاع عدد الضحايا من
المدنيين منذ بدايه الاشتباكات التي
اندلعت بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الى
198 قتيلا وقالت اللجنه في بيانها ان
التوتر الحاصل بين المكونين العسكريين في
السودان خلف
1207 مصابين حتى الان اشار البيان الى
وجود عدد من القتلى والجرحى غير مشمولين
في هذا الحصر بسبب صعوبه الوصول الى
المستشفيات اراسل العربيه فادا بوجود
اشتباكات في ام درمان وتحليق للطيران
الحربي في سماء الخرطوم صباح اليوم من
جهتها كدت قوات الدعم السريعه انها تصدت
لهجوم من الجيش على تمركزاتها في غرب ام
درمان مشيره الى اسقاطها مروحيتين خلال
التصدي للهجوم
الله اكبر
السريع
المقام هاربين منها تم استلام عدد خمسه
عربه لاندك وعدد واحد تنكر ماء وعدد جاك
خمر وكميه من الاسلحه
بفضله في هذه الساعه
وتم الاستدلال على عدد خمسه عرب كنوزر
حريق في مهند للسلاح مهند للسلاح حريق في
الخرطوم اثنين شارع الصناعات شارع
الصناعات
العمارات
قاعده فوق ما قادره تطلع حريق حريق
حريق من حلبي تعذيرا
[تصفيق]
يا جماعه ان ده استغاثه لاي زول بيعرف اي
جهه مطافي اي جهه ممكن تيجي تتدخل في
الحته دي الناس المفروض تجي في الحته دي
فوق سرقعت فوق علقه فوق اطفال قاعدين فوق
في العماره والناس
وفي تلاته ولا اكتر من اربع عمارات موجوده
تحت لبعض وهادي الناس حسك على التجري
نداء استغاثه يا جماعه في اكتر من اربع
عمارات جنب بعض يفوز قاعده فوق ما قادر
تنزل
وانا من مدينه مروين مراسل العربيه
ما الجديد في مروي في اليوم السادس
تحيه صباحا الجديد في مروي هو استمرار
حاله الهدوء النسبي التي سادت في ارجاء
المحليه والولايه بعد اعلان الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه خروج اخر مجموعه
من مجموعات الدعم السريع التي كانت تتمركز
داخل قاعده ومطار مروي الدولي
الان الانتشار هو سيد الموقف لاليات
ولعتاد القوات المسلحه السودانيه
بالمدفعيه
وبالاليات الثقيله المختلفه في محيط
المطار في حدود المطار جنوبا في حدود
المطار ايضا شمالا في مداخل المطار حتى ان
الجيش الان بدا يتمركز في عدد من النقاط
لخلق حاله من الطمانينه لدى المواطنين
الذين استشعروا حاله من الطمانين النسبيه
وبداوا في مزاوله حياتهم الاعتياديه ان لم
تكن كما كانت خلال قبل الاحداث السبت
الماضي السوق الرئيسي في المدينه بدات
رويدا وشيئا فشيئا تعود اليه حركه
الاقتصاد خاصه وانهم اي المواطنون على بعد
يوم او ساعات من عيد الفطر المبارك
عليه فان الامور الان تمضي نحو الهدوء على
ما يبدو من واقع الانتشار الكثيف للقوات
المسلحه والتاكيدات المستمره على انه لا
وجود لقوات الدعم السريع في مروي بعد ان
تم التعامل معها عبر المدفعيه وعبر السلاح
الطيران الجوي ماذا عن المناطق التي شهدت
مواجهات بين كره الدعم السريع
وقوات الجيش يعني في في مروي الان كيف هي
اوضاع هذه المناطق خصوصا المطار يعني ما
حجم الدمار الذي خلفت هذه المواجهات فيه
ما حدث خلال الايام الماضيه الايام الخمس
من اشتباكات ومن العمليات عسكريه كانت كل
هذه الاشتباكات كما يقول مواطنون هنا في
مروه بانهم محظوظون لان الاشتباكات ونرى
الحرب لم تمتد الى داخل المدينه ولم تمتد
الى الشريط القروي الذي يمتد شمالا وجنوبا
على حدود القاعده والمطار داخل المطار
كانت تدور العمليه العسكريه والاشتباكات
يوم امس عندما سجلنا زياره خاصه لمطار
مروي والقاعده لاحظنا حجم الدمار الذي
اصاب المطر اصاب برج المراقبه اصاب
المرافق الحيويه اسباب اصاب السيارات
الاطفاء اصاب المدرج بعض القطع التابعه
للطيران ايضا تاثرت المخازن التي تقدم اول
الورش التي تقدم التعامل اللوجستي وعمليات
الصيانه للطائرات ايضا تاثرت
المكاتب الاداريه تاثرت لمطارات كبير داخل
المطار مروي الدولي وربما يحتاج الى وقت
حتى يستعيد هذا المطار عافيته ويقدم من
جديد على تقديم الخدمات الجويه والملاحيه
سواء للسودان او لبقيه الدول باعتبار ان
هذا المطار هو مطار في منطقه استراتيجيه
ومطار دولي ويساند كثيرا مطار الخرطوم
الدولي
هذا الدمار يعني هل كان نتيجه المواجهات
نزار ام تدمير ربما متعمد من قبل عناصر
القوات الدعم السريع قبل انسحابها من
المنطقه
في هذه المنطقه كانت على اشدها وكانت
ضاريه
وفيها اهليات متنوعه استخدمت فيها الياف
ثقيله واستخدمت فيها المدفعيه واستخدمت
فيها الراجمات واستخدم فيها ساون
الثنائي والهاء والمضادات الطائرات
الطيران الجوي هذه التشكيله المتنوعه من
الاسلحه ومن العتاده الحربي
ربما هي من تسبب في هذا الوضع الذي يعيشه
مطار مروي حاليا الوضع الذي كان في المطار
كان يشير وينذر بان ارضيه المطار بان
مرافق المطار حتما لن تسلم من النيران
سواء كان من هنا او من هنا خاصه وانه كان
المسرح الرئيسي للعمليه العسكريه شكرا
جزيلا لك نزار بقداوي مراسل العربيه من
مدينه مروي
محاور عده للنزاع في السودان من ابرزها ما
يدور في العاصمه لكن الاعين تتوجه ايضا
لمنطقه اخرى الى اكبر ولايات السودان
الولايه الشماليه التي برز من بين مدنها
بشكل لافت مروي الواقعه على بعد 350
كيلومترا شمال العاصمه الخرطوم المدينه
ذات اهميه عسكريه كبيره ازدادت مع الصراع
الحالي بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع جل
التركيز صب على مطار المدينه للجانبين
المدني والعسكري وتضاربت الانباء حول
الجانب المسيطر عليه الى ان اعلن الجيش عن
اعاده السيطره على مطار مروي المطار يعتبر
قاعده جويه مسانده ومنطقه تمركز بديله
للقواعد العسكريه الاخرى في السودان ويغطي
مطارها العمليات الجويه في شمال السودان
وشرقه وغربه اهميه مطار مروي تتاتى من
كونه احد اكبر المطارات في افريقيا فهو
يقع على مساحه 18 كيلوم وهو مصمم لاستيعاب
هبوط واقلاع الطائرات الضخمه بمهبط طائرات
بطول حوالي اربعه كيلو مترات وعرض 60 مترا
وفي مطار مروي ومحيطه تنتشر قوات الفرقه
تسعه عشر التابعه للجيش السوداني المسؤوله
عن حمايه المرافق الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
وقد فادت صحيفه فورن بوليسي نقلا عن مصادر
مطلعه بان الاداره الامريكيه تستعد لفرض
عقوبات على طرفي النزاع في السودان وتشير
المصادر الى ان العقوبات التي لم ينجز او
لم تعد حتى الان ستطال مسؤولين في القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريعه
على حد سوى في الوقت ذاته اعرباء مسؤولون
امريكيون عن مخاوفهم من ان العقوبات لن
تكون كافيه وتاتي متاخره وفيما يخص الجنود
المصريين اعلن الجيش السوداني في بيان له
اجلاء 177 جنديا مصريا كانوا محتجزين في
مروي من قبل الدعم السريع اضاف البيان بان
عمليات رجله تمت عبر 4 طائرات عسكريه
مصريه من مطار الدنجل واوضح ان وجود
الاطقم الفنيه المصريه بالسودان كان بموجب
بروتوكول تدريب مشترك وحول الانباء
المتداوله عن تداخلبي في الصراع نفت
القوات المسلحه الليبيه بقياده خليفه
تقديم الدعم لطرف ضد الاخر من طرفي صراع
الدائره في السودان واوضح المتحدث باسم
الجيش الوطني الليبي احمد المسماري ان
القوات المسلحه لبيه تقوم حاليا باجراء
اتصالات عاجله مع الاطراف المعنيه مضيفا
بان القياده مستعده للقيام بالدور الوسط
والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا فشيئا
لحاره مجاوره واخرت لها طالما ان
الجنرالين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفوته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديجوري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او ديفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرلين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايد ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
الخرطوم ينضم لنا الصحه في خالد الفك سيد
خالد اهلا وسهلا بك معي بدايه كيف تقيم
الاوضاع اليوم في اليوم السادس لهذه
المواجهات ولماذا تفشل
الهدن ولا تلتزم بها الاطراف المتصارعه
حتى له
[تصفيق]
قبل ان اذهب في الاجابه لسؤالك فنقل اليك
خبر مهم وعادل من بعض المصادر الصحفيه قبل
قليل تواصلت معهد الزملاء الصحفيين الذي
يسكن في حي الاسكان 61 وهو بالقرب من
معسكر لدعم السريع في منطقه صالحه وقال
وابلغني انه سقط ثلاثه ركله واربع جرحى
بسبب سقوط اداءنا في منزلهم وان المنطقه
منذ الامس لم يعني النوم وكانت في حاله من
القلق والخوف بسبب المحاولات الجيش الجيش
السوداني هجوم وقطع الطريق لانداد من
الدعم السريع في طريق الخرطومباره والذي
هو غربي منطقه الموالح فكان هناك هجوم قال
انهم كانوا منذ
منذ سادسه مساء وحتى قبل اقل من نصف ساعه
كانت المعارك وكانت الغنابل واستخدام كافه
كافه انواع الاسلحه الصغيره في هذه
المنطقه وان الجيش ربما استطاع بشكل كبير
عن يعني
يشتت هذه القوه ويفرق جمعها بعد ان اجتمعت
وربما بعدها الامداد الذي كان ياتي اليها
من مناطق اخرى في طريقها الى الخرطوم اما
فيما يتعلق
باستمرار حتى هذه اللحظات وعلى شده نحن
كنا نتوقع ونحن ندخل اليوم السادس ان تعد
الاوضاع وان يتجه الطرفان الى التهديه
وتنفيذ الهدنه التي يعني تم الاعلان عنها
امس لمده 24 ساعه ولكن بالدليل يعني كل
المورده الزمنيه
التي لم تحقق نجاحا وربما يعني عدم
التزامن في اعلانها من قبل الطرفين مسارات
امنه
وتحديد مراقبين ربما هو الذي يعني يبوظ
الى فشل
مثل هذه
الهدن كما انه وفقي المصادر متطابقه ان
هناك مازال عالقونا في خضم هذه المنطقه
التي تحيط بالاشتباك حيث علمنا ان هناك
اسر تسكن في مقر
مصر وهو في عشر تقاطع في الخرطوم ويقود
الى القياده مباشره البلديه مع القصر او
عفوا مع نمر حيث علمنا ان هناك نحو يعني
اكثر من 25 شخص عالقين في البترون منذ
تفجر الازمه وهم الان يعانون من اوضاع
انسانيه حريه جدا
و بينهم الصحفي يدعى اسماعيل نحاول
التواصل ومحاوله ايجاد وسيله للتواصل
عليهم
ومحاوله اخراجهم وتوفير
يعني ممر
لخروجهم وهذا يدلل يشير الى انه ربما جعل
هناك كثير من العالقين في يعني
في هذه المباني ولا يستطيعون التحدث في ظل
انقطاع الكهرباء في ظل الان فقدان
الهواتف الذكيه
للطاقه فاذا الاوضاع الانسانيه تتدهور
يعني بالامس شاهدت عدد من الاسر تحاول ان
تخرج من الخرطوم او تحاول ان تخرج من
الاحياء القريبه من محيط الاشتباكات الان
هناك اشكاليات تتعلق بالحصول على المواد
الاستهلاكيه الرئيسيه او الان هناك الصفوف
بدات طويله في الحصول على الخبز
فكل هذا يعني يضاعف من المعاناه في ظل
انفتاح الدعم السريع على بعض الاحياء
ومحاوله يعني
الابتعاد من اداره الاحداث قدر الامكان
بعد ان اعاده الجيش السوداني تموض شعره في
محيط القياده العامه والان هناك يعني عدد
من الشوارع الرئيسه خاصه المتعلقه بمحيط
القياده العامه هي تكاد تكون مناصفه بين
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني يدرس
الداخليه قالت في بيان متاخر من ليله امس
ان الدعم السريع يعني حاجه وادخل مسلحين
في بعض المقارنه التابعه لوزاره الداخليه
على راسها مبنى السجل المدني وسلطه المرور
المرور وهذا يشير الى ان الدعم السريع
الان اصبح خارج يعني يعني اغلب قواته لم
يعني تبقى موجوده في محيط دائره دائره
القياده والقصري وابتعدت نحو نصف كيلو من
اليوم الاول والثاني والثالث التي كانت
تقول انها مسيطره وهي داخل القياده وداخل
القطر الجمهوري فاذا الاوضاع الميدانيه
يبدو انها تتازم وان الطرفان يتوس
في الحرب خاصه بعد تصريحات البرهاني التي
يعني نقلت قبل قليل عبر العربيه
لاحدى الصحف وان السبيل الوحيد لارساء
الديمقراطيه هو ازاحه كما يقول البرهان
وان
حميتي يقول انه لا مجال للتزحزح وان
الميدان سيحدد كل شيء اذا يبدو ان
الجنرالان الان يتصارعان بقوه وان يعني
هذا مما يشيء ويفسر بان ربما تكون هناك
مزيد من السباكات ومزيد من من الالتحامات
القويه وهذا يمشي بان يعني هناك توقعات
بمزيد من الضحايا القتلى وعدد من الجرحى
انا اتحدث اليك خالد وهناك معلومات وردتني
ايضا بان هناك الان اشتباكات عنيفه تقع في
دائره او في ضاحيه ضاحيه جبر التي تبعد
نحو
15 الى 17 كيلو من القياده العامه وبالقرب
من اهم ثلاثه مقار عسكريه خاصه وحده
المدرعات التي لا يقصف بينها وبين الجبره
سوى يعني
امتار قليله كذلك التصنيع الحربي والذي
يعني كان هو الذي يمد الجيش بكافه
التصنيعات الحربيه بجانب ايضا مطلع مصنع
الذخيره فاذا يبدو ان الان المعارك بدت
تنتقل من دائره القياده العامه ومحيطها
الى مناطق اقل بعدا نحو كيلو الى كيلو
ونصف الى اثنين كيلو حيث علمنا خالد ان
هناك الان ايضا تجمع كبير للدعم السريع في
منطقه شرق النيل تحديدا كبري المنشيه عند
مستشفى مستشفى الشرق النيل وان كانوا سريع
يعني اغلى منطقه الرعب مستشفى الراغي التي
كان فيها المصابين العلاج وذلك بسبب عدم
التامين
الخشيه للمهاجمه المهاجمه القوات المسلحه
وذهب الى هذه المنطقه الاستراتيجيه والتي
هي منطقه شرق النيل فبالتالي الان يبدو ان
هناك مخالف جديده من نقل الصراع الى
الاحياء الى مناطق الحيويه
وتضيق بالسكان وهذا يعني ينذر بحربي شوارع
وحرب اهليه حتى هذه اللحظه خالد
ساعود اليك في ثنايا هذه التغطيه
بالخدمه ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
القوات البريه السند للغات البريه
65 دبابه الان كلها محروقه الان وهي بعين
بالعمل
القياده العامه
لحد الان
بينعمل 65 دبابه اللي هي
المسانده للقياده العامه
اللي هو الاول
البريه 65 دبابه
[موسيقى]
حول التداعيات الصحيه والمعيشيه الصعبه
التي يعيشها السودانيون في هذه الظروف حذر
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي من ان القتال في
السودان يهدد الملايين بالمجاعه وفي
تصريحاته للعربيه ناشد المدير الاقليمي
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه احمد المندري نشد
الاطراف السودانيه الالتزام بالقوانين
الدوليه مشيرا الى ان ما يحدث في السودان
اكبر من قدره الهيئات الصحيه اكد المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه الدكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن في لقاء مع العربيه ان
خروج بعض المستشفيات عن الخدمه في الخرطوم
لم يشكل عبئا على سير النظام الصحي وقال
المتحدث بان المستشفيات التي خرجت عن
الخدمه كانت بسبب وقوعها في مرمى النيران
وتمت تفريغها لمستشفيات بديله امنه
الاطراف المتنازعه الالتزام
بقانون الدولي المختص بهذا الموضوع وحمايه
ارواح المدنيين خلال هذه النزاعات لكن
للاسف كما هو معروف لا يغلب يعني صوت
العقل خلال هذه المحن والازمات وانما يغلب
صوت السلاح للاسف فنناشد كذلك يعني الجميع
داخل السودان ان يلتزموا بالاخذ الحيطه
والحذر وعدم الخروج الى الاماكن الخطره
حتى يضمنوا كذلك يعني التزام الاطراف
المتنازعه بالهده وبالتالي عدم تعرض
تعرضهم للمخاطر وفقدان الارواح الكثيره
المسلسلات التي خرجت من الخدمه عشر
مستشفيات عامه في القطاع العام و20 مستشفى
القطاع الخاص عدد المسلسلات التي خرجت لا
تشكل عبئا على على سير النظام الصحي لانه
عدد الاسير الموجود عندنا هو انا مستغل
30% من مغدره المسلسلات على تقديم الخدمات
الصحيه التردد الان في ظل تقديم الخدمه
يساوي 0.2% من التردد الطبيعي في الاوقات
الطبيعيه وبالتالي
وبالتالي خروج المستشفيات عدد من
المستشفيات لانها في مرمى النار لان
المسيفرات غير امنه وتم تفريغها لمستشفيات
امنه بديله هذا لا لا ينذر بانهيار النظام
الصحي كما يقولون يعني
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا رئيس تحرير صحيفه
التيار عثمان ميرغني سيد عثمان اهلا وسهلا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه من خلال متابعتك
الان لهذه الحرب والمواجهات خصوصا في
اليوم السادس الى اي مدى
يمكنني القول بانها افرزت واقعا جديدا
اليوم في السودان
الوصول الحرب الى يومها السادس بالضروره
يعني ان هناك متغيرات جديده وان هناك واقع
جديد يكرس خاصه على المستوى الانساني وعلى
مستوى
المستوى الحياه العاديه للمواطنه العادي
الذي لاول مره يشهد مثل هذه الاحداث لم
يتعود السودانيين على مثل هذه الاحداث في
هذه المدن الكبرى خاصه الخرطوم كانت صحيح
موجوده في بعض المناطق البعيده لكن لاول
مره يتعايشوا مع هذه الحرب كانت في
البدايه هناك صدمه لكن الان بعد مرور سته
ايام بدا النوع من التعايش مع هذا الوضع
في ظروف بالغه السوء خاصه الظفر الانساني
واياب كافه
الخدمات الصحيه والخدمات الحتميه مثل
المياه وغير ذلك التي يعتمد عليها المواطن
في حياته العاديه فهناك الان نوع من
التعايش مع هذا الوضع ومحاوله تكييف
الحياه حتى يتحملوا هذه الظروف القاسيه
الى ابعد مدى ممكن في انتظار ان يكون في
النهايه هناك امل للخروج من هذه الحاله
الميدان هو هو ربما النتيجه التي يحتكم
اليها الطرفان في هذا الصراع لكن هل يمكن
لاحدهما ان يقضي على الاخر سيد عثمان
واصلا ليست من الاهداف الاستراتيجيه
القضاء على الاخر يعني لم يعلن طرف منهما
انه يريد القضاء بهذه العباره على الاخر
اهداف محدده بالنسبه لقوات الدعم السريع
قالت ان هدفها الاساسي الاستراتيجي الذي
دفع عليه هو التغيير قياده القوات المسلحه
وليس القضاء المسلحه بالنسبه للجيش له هدف
محدد وهو اخضاع طريق القضاء على قوات
الدعم يعني ان يحافظ عليها
بل قدم اليها عروضا قدموا عروض يعني على
رؤوس الاشهاد كانت هناك بيانات من الجيش
السوداني يدعو فيه بنود الدعم السريه
للانضمام الى القوات المسلحه ووعده من
يستسلم ان يتم
القوات المسلحه فاذا
الطرفان لا يسعى الى القضاء على بعض لكن
هناك اهداف استراتيجيه لكل واحد منهم
يحاول ان يحققه هذه الاهداف هي التي تفكر
سير المعارك حتى الان لكن التصريحات ما
يحدث الى الارض ومختلف عن ذلك تماما يعني
التصريحات تقول الجيش عندما يعتبر بان هذه
الميليشيات يعني خائنه غادره
مدمره فهو
الى القضاء عليها ثم هل يمكن بالفعل
البقاء في هذه المعادله يعني ان تبقى هذه
الميليشيات ولكن تواجه الان بهذه القوه
كما يحدث في الخرطومه في غيرها من المناطق
يعني انا اريد ان اقوله كان ان
الاهداف النهائيه التي ذكرت عليها لسان
الطرفين هي تدل على سير المعارك يعني
الطريقه التي يمكن ان تدير بها المعارك
وتدل على الطريقه التي يمكن بعد ذلك ان
تعتبر احد الطرفين قد انتصر على الطرف
الاخر فعلى سبيل المثال اللوحه في اليوم
السادس اليوم ان هناك انحشاء كبير جدا في
المعارك خاصه المكان الذي لم يتوقف فيه
صوت الرصاص والقنابل ولا دقيقه واحده خلال
السته ايام وهو مسرح القياده العامه هذه
المنطقه يتزلط مشتعله منذ اللحظه الاولى
حتى قبل ساعات قليله لكنها الان حسب
الذكور هذه المنطقه تمثل الهدف
الاستراتيجي الذي قوات الدعم السريع وهو
الوصول الى قياده الجيش بالتاكيد اذا لم
تستطع ان تدير المعارك بهذا المكان
وانشغلت بمناطق اخرى او انسحبت الى مناطق
اخرى من العاصمه فهذا يعني الفشل للوصول
الى وبالتالي تصبح كل العمليات التي تقوم
بها لا جدوى منها لانها لن تحقق الهدف
الذي من اجله تحاول الوصول اليه اما
بالنسبه للجيش فهو كان الهدف التكتيكي
الاول هو السيطره على كل القواعد التي
تنطلق منها
وحقق ذلك الهدف لكنه انتقل الان الى
المرحله الثانيه وهي محاوله محاصره القوات
في اماكن اخرى خاصه داخل الاحياء
والتجمعات التي تقوم بها في اماكن بعيده
من مقرها السابقه في محاوله لتجفيف وجوده
بصوره كامله في المسارح العمليات في داخل
العاصمه ربما تنتقل بعد ذلك الى مكان اخر
لكن في النهايه ان يكون ذلك نوع من اخضاع
هذه القوات للجيش السوداني دون الحاجه الى
القضاء على كل الاعضاء او الجنود هذه
القوات
ساعود اليك ايضا نتابع هذه التطورات الان
المشهد العسكري وكذلك السياسي في السودان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعوذ لضيفي من الخرطوم رئيس تحرير صحيفه
التيارات من مرغني السيد عثمان هذا الغموض
الان في ساحات المعارك لا يمكن الجزم ابدا
الان بميلان الكفته لطرف دون اخر
الاشتباكات تتجدد بشكل عنيف ربما في مناطق
تخفي مناطق
وتشتد في مناطق اخرى كل ذلك انسحب كذلك
الى حالته غموض في المواقف السياسيه
في السودان داخليه وكذلك على المستوى
الشعبي يعني كيف يجب ان يتم اليوم يعني
اليوم السادس في هذه الحرب ان يتم التعامل
مع هذه الحاله من هذه الناحيه الناحيه
السياسيه المواقف الشعبيه ايضا
نعم ربما هي واحده من اهم الجوانب التي
يجب ان تتحرك في هذا الظرف بالتحديد لان
الحرب الان هي ليست فقط يعني
النتائج هذه الحرب ليست فقط فيما يدور
الان من قتال في المناطق المختلفه والدماء
التي تسيل هذه اللحظيا اثناء القتال او
اثناء الحرب لكن مترتبات الحرب هي الاخطر
بمعنى انه بعد ان تنتهي الحرفه وتضع
اودارها لكنها
ستخلف كثير من الاثار الخطيره جدا وبعضها
قد يتعدى
مناطق القتال في العاصمه الى مناطق اخرى
وتخلف نوع من الانقسام في البلاد بصوره
تهدد وحده البلاد هذا العمل يجب ان يتم
بواسطه القوات السياسيه ان تحاول منذ الان
والحرب الدائره ان تستدرك هذه الاوضاع
وتضع من الخطط والمواقف ما يمكن ان يتجنب
اثار الحرب على المد قصير وانا اعتقد ان
هذه الخطوه هي خطوه عاجله جدا يجب ان تتم
الان ان تبدا بتوحيد القوى السياسيه حول
الاهداف يعني ليس توحيد بمعنى جمع الشمل
بصوره كامله هي فقط ان تكون لهم اهداف
فيجتهدون حولها يعملوا معا وهذه القوه
السياسيه مطلوب منها بعد ذلك ان تسعى
لتحقيق هذه الاهداف وعلى راسها ان توقف
الحرب وان توقف اطلاق النار ثم بعد ذلك ان
تقدم مباشره بعد اطلاق وقف اطلاق النار
حلل سياسيا للازمه التي كانت سبب هذا هذه
الحرب وانا اعتقد ان هذا الامر لا ينتظر
يعني يجب ان يبدا الان والا فان مترتبات
هذه الحرب ستكون اكبر كبيرا كثيرا من
الحرب نفسها
اريد فقط المشاهد الخبر العاجل لان الجيش
المصري يقول بانه تم التامين عوده كل
القوات المصريه من السودان اليوم بالتنسيق
مع الصليب الاحمر
وبان هناك ثلاث طائرات تنقل عسكريه قامت
امس بمهمه اخلاء القوات المصريه من
السودان عاود لك سيد عثمان
اذا لم يتسنى ذلك يعني الدخول بمبادرات
ربما وضع مبادرات وهو الامر الذي نشاهده
حتى الان هل يجب على الشعب السوداني وعلى
هذه القوه ان تغادر حاله الحياد التي هي
عليها الان ان تتجه ربما الاصطفاف مع احد
الطرفين المتصارعين ومن هو برايك
يعني الاصتصاص المباشر بمعنى ان تقديم نوع
من الدعم المباشر لاحد الطرفين ربما لا
يكون مفيد للقوات السياسيه ولا لاي من
الطرفين لان هناك
كفه اخرى يمكن ان ترجح كل ذلك وهو كفى
التي تمثل الشعب بصوره عامه والجماهير هذه
هي الكفه التي ترجح اي اصطفاف مع اي من
الطرفين وهذه الكفه من الصعوبه بمكان ان
تكون الى اي جهه غير الجيش السوداني الان
من متابعه عبر الوقايه التواصل واللقاءات
المباشره اذا حصل ان السودانيين برغم
خلافاتهم السياسيه الكبيره والعميقه الا
انهم يجتهدون حول جيشهم وهذا امر طبيعي
وربما ذلك ما لحظته قوات الدعم السريع في
خطابها كانت دائما توجه النقد اللي قائد
الجيش وليس للجيش وكانت تقدم كثير من
البيان الذي يوضح انها لا تق في نفسه
وانما تقصد قياده الجيش وهذا نوع من
الاعتراف بان حساسيه استهداف الجيش كمؤسسه
لما لها من من
مكانه عند الشعب السوداني فاذا القوه
السياسيه لن تستطيع هنا ان ان تحاول ان
تغامر
بشعبيتها بان تضع نفسها في مواجهه لن يكون
مفيدا منها لكن المطلوب من القوات
السياسيه دائما هو تحقيق الاهداف يعني هو
ليس يعني مجرد التعاطف مع طرف من الاطراف
انما محاوله بلوره الاطرى الاهداف بشكل
اعمال ومقترحات ومبادرات وتقديمها بالصوره
التي يمكن ان تؤثر فعلا في المشهد
الموجوده الان وانا في تقديري هي عمليه
اذا لم تقم بها القوه السياسيه فبالروره
ذلك ان يعني مزيد من التدوين لقضيه
السودانيه لان الفراغ سيملاه بعد ذلك
التدخل الدولي شكرا جزيلا لك كانت صحيفه
التيار كنت معي من الخرطوم
تيجاني مسلتي كان احد ابرز جنود احتجاجات
ديسمبر قاد المظاهرات التي اندلعت في
السودان اواخر العام 2018 قدم خدمات
علاجيه للمحتاجين وشارك في العديد من
الانشطه الميدانيه والاغاثيه لم يكن يعلم
انه سيكون ضحيه الاشتباكه الجاريه في
السودان قتل بعد ان سقطت عليه قذيفه في
مكان اقامته جراء الاقتتال الدائري بين
الجيش والدعم السريع نعاه زملائه في العمل
الطوعي ووصفوه باحد الجنود المجهولين
لثوره ديسون مخاوف انهيار الوضع الصحي
بشكل كامل ليس المشكله الوحيده الان هناك
ازمه مياه في الخرطوم تتفاقم ايضا بعد
مرور اكثر من خمسه ايام على انقطاعها
بالكامل على معظم المناطق السكنيه في
العاصمه يعيش السودانيون اليوم ظروفا صعبه
بسبب انقطاع المياه والكهرباء معا ومزاد
من معاناتهم ايضا نقص الغذاء وشح الخدمات
الاساسيه في ظل استمرار الاشتباكات
المهندسين
استخدموا الابار الجوفيه والمعاناه كبيره
جدا درجه الحراره مرتاحه وانقطاع الكهرباء
ما بين فتره واخرى وانتم كثير جدا من
الاحياء والمربعات المجاوره رجل لنفس
الاتجاه والمنطقه بقت منطقه الناس بيكونوا
موجودين فيها وبياخدوا منها المياه
الجوفيه وهي مياه برده مش صالحه للشرب غدر
ما هي ممكن يتم استخدامها في اشياء ثانيه
بعد غروب الشمس تتناول هذه الاسره
السودانيه الفاتوره في لحظه صمت تنقطع فيه
اصوات المدافع ويرتفع صوت الاذان في
استراحه قصيره من الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
الضائقه الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها السودان
منذ سنوات يسعى المواطنون لتجاهلها ولو
مؤقتا على مائده الافطار حيث باتت واقعا
يؤرقهم لا يمكنهم توقع تبعاته في ظل
القتال المحتدم
وبالرغم من انهم ربما تجاهلوا بشكل مؤقت
مشاكلهم الاقتصاديه الا نزمات الغذاء التي
تلوح في الافق اصبحت حقيقه واقعه في
السودان استمرار القتال تسبب في تفاقم
الوضع الانساني المتازم بالفعل خمسه عشر
مليون شخص بالكاد تتوفر لديهم مستلزمات
الغذاء الاساسيه بحسب تقرير للامم المتحده
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان نحو اربعه ملايين
طفل دون الخامسه يعانون من بوادر سوء
التغذيه
المعارك الدائره حاليا
مباشره في البنيه التحتيه عائلات بالكامل
استبدلت المشروبات الرمضانيه بالمياه
بعدما استهدفت محطات المياه في بعض
الاحياء مثل بحر شمالي الخرطوم
عائلات اخرى لجات الى الاكتفاء بوجبه
واحده فقط في اليوم في سبيل التعايش مع
الظروف الصعبه الاحياء الاوفر حظا يقتنص
سكانها فرصه هدوء الاشتباكات ليهرعوا الى
محلات البقاله ليجدوا ارففها فارغه تماما
خاصه التي تحتوي على المياه المعدنيه
اغلب الاحتياجات نقدر نجيبه بالنسبه
لاغلاق الطعم لسوبر ماركت والدكاكين
السيناريو الاكثر سوءا الذي لم يتوقعه
السودانيون كان اعلان برنامج الغذاء
العالمي وقفه مساعداته للبلاد على وقع
مقتل ثلاثه من موظفيه نتيجه الاشتباكات
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
الخرطوم ينضم لنا الصحفي خالد الفقي سيد
خالد يعني كيف يتعامل السودانيون الان مع
هذه الازمات خاصه انقطاع الكهرباء شحل
المياه والغذاء والدواء ايضا اذا كان هناك
نضاف نضافه يعني
نعم نعم اعتقد انسانين في السودان او على
الاقل في الخرطوم ومحيط دائره الاحداث
ومسرح العمليات
قد معقده جدا
في الحصول على المياه خاصه بعد ان قال
الجيش ان الاكوان
يستهدفت محطات وخزانات المياه الرئيسه في
بعض المناطق
المهمه والاستراتيجيه
فمن اصابه بالضرر
الخرطوم ان هناك فرقيه الان تحاول الاصلاح
المد المد الممنوخ المياه
الشبكات مجددا
قبل ان هناك مناطق كثيره هي بلاء مياه
ايضا هناك خروج للكهرباء كثير من
المحطات هي تخرج بسبب عدم توفر الجهاز
والوقود كما قالت الهيئه اربعه بالحجر ان
الخرقوم او السودان ربما هو على مشارف
الاطفاء التام فهي يعني يتم التوزيع ربما
جديد للكهرباء من خلال محاوله قطع التيار
طويله ومنحي لبعض الاحياء ربما للدقائق
الوقت القصير وهكذا حتى يعني تكون هناك
امكانيه
يعني وجود الكهرباء ولكنه
الكهرباء او اداره الكهرباء تقول ان هناك
اشكالات حقيقيه في توفر الكهرباء فضلا عن
ذلك اشكاليه تتعلق بالمواد الغذائيه
وتدفرها بسبب اغلاق الاسواق والمحل
التجاريه الكبيره ايضا بسبب التوقف وانتاج
المصانع خشيه ما يحدث من اشتباكات وايضا
هناك اشكاليه تتعلق بالان الحصول على ربما
الخبز من خلال
يعني اختصرت الحصول على الخطبه
بمبلغ محدد حتى تتيح اكبر فرصه لمن على
شرائح الامم الخالد يمكن الاشاره الى الان
هناك حاله من الخوف والجذع يعيشها ان
السودانيين وهم مقبلين على مشاركه عيد
الفطر المبارك وربما منذ الاستغلال لم
يعني جيش على الاقل سكان هذه الاحداث
المفارقات العجيبه خالد ان هناك احياء
خارج دائره الاشتباكات ومسرح العمليات
يعني الحياه فيها تكاد تكون عاديه مثل مثل
مناطق شمال ام درمان في
جنوان مثل منطقه صابرين او الثورات او غرب
الحارات
فهذه المناطق الى حد كبير هي امنه ومستقره
ولا يعني توجد فيها اشك كما تحدث هنا في
الخرطوم فضل ايضا المناطق اخرى يعني تبعد
نسبيا
جنوب الخرطوم مثل مناطق التقينات او يعني
بعض المناطق الكلاكلات وابوادهم اذن الان
يمكن ان يكون هناك في يوجد يعني استقرار
نسبي في بعض
المناطق في الخرطوم ولكنها هي مربوطه
ببعدها من اداره الاحداث التي تصل الى
اجرين الى 25 كيلو وربما يصعب ان ان تكون
في دائره الاحداث تنتقل انها الاحداث من
خلال هذا التموضع الدعم الذي هو كما شئت
اليك خلال المداخله
حاول ان ينتشر في مناطق لم يعني يكون فيها
هدف استراتيجي
يبدو انه كان
استرالي هو الدخول الى المواقع الحساسه
الافتراضيه خاصه
القياده العامه والقصر الجمهوري وبعض
الوزارات ولكن الان القوه الاكبر من الدعم
السريع هي خارج دائره الفيلم والمسرح
العمليات حقيقه
احياء الجنوبيه والحياه الشرقيه من
العاصمه الان نحن نتابع هذه الصور خصوصا
من محيط ربما الان تعود ربما الدخان
للتصاعد مره اخرى ربما هذا في مؤشر الى
عوده
المواجهات لم نكن نستمع الى اصوات اطلاق
النيران في هذه المنطقه تحديدا خلال يعني
الساعه الماضيه خالد في مقارنه ايضا ربما
في محيط القصر الجمهوري لمبات تتحدث عن
خفوت كذلك ربما في هذه المواجهات
فهل يمكن الحديث عن حاله هدوء نسبيه في في
وسط العاصمه السودانيه اليوم هل يمكن
الحديث عن افضليه الطرف عن طرف في مناطق
المواجهات ربما في محيط القصر الجمهوري او
في محيط القياده العامه خالد
اعتقد انه من خلال الصوره التي تمثل على
قناه العربيه هي تبدو ان هذا هذا المشهد
اقرب الى منطقه اداره الاحداث بالقرب من
القياده العامه المنطقه الشرجيه تحديدا
ربما منطقه جامعه الخرطوم
التي تجاورها وهي قريبه من القياده العامه
وايضا كبري الكبري الحديد
الازرق وما هو معروف ان هناك قوه كبيره من
الدعم السريع انتشرت في منطقه بحري في
احياء محمد
فربما الان هناك قد تكون يعني محاولات
لمحاوله الدخول مجددا الى دائره الاحداث
ومحاوله الاسناد وسلسله من الامداد لهذه
القوه
فبالتالي يعني اتوقع ان يتم التعامل معها
من القوات المسلحه ولكن ربما يعني تكون
الافضليه وفق البيان الذي قاله الجيش
عشيره الامس وفي الساعات الاولى من اليوم
انه يعني عاد كموضوع هو انتشاره في محيط
القياده العامه وربما يعني نلحق ذلك من
خلال انخفاض وتيره
الاحداث وتصاعدها بالامس
يعني قبله كنا خالد مشاهد اشتعال النيران
وتصاعد الدخان وان الصحب الدخان تكاد تكون
تحجب الاحياء الشرقيه
لمطابق الطمى القياده العامه هذه الامر لم
نعد كما كان بالامس ربما بناء وهناك يعني
انخفاض في وتيره الاحداث والاشتبات مما
يشير ويدلل على ان القوات المسلحه اعاده
موضوعها وانتشارها وتمسك المبادره خاصه في
في الجانب الشرقي للقياده العامه ومثالث
خرطوم من الشرقيه في في طريق الذي يعني
يؤدي الى الجيش كوبر ويؤدي غربا او جنوبا
الى احياء وضواحي الرياض والمنشيه
وايضا هناك الكويت فيبدو ان الجيش وقطع
الطريق امام الدعم السريع الذي كان له قوه
بالامس يعني
بقوه وقاتلت بقوه واستماده في هذا المحور
ولكن نبدو ان الجيش صدها تماما ولكن ان
نتوقع ان اتخان الذي نراه اليوم وجدته
سحابه بيضاء وليس صحابه
ولم نرى استعاد النيران يعني الان يبدو
انه اشتباك في الارض وليس هناك استخدام
سلاح السلاح الطيران لاسقطاب من من ويبدو
انه من خلال مدافع ومضادات ارضيه داخليه
المسلحه في محاولات للرد للدوله السريه
الذي يبدو انه يحاول الهجوم وان يبدو ان
القوات المسلحه تحاول الدفاع وتغلق الطريق
هذا ما يبدو لي من المسجد الذي اراه امامي
وبحكم المعلومات التي تشير الى ان الدعم
له قوه ايضا
المنتشره في تحرير خاصه في قصر الصداقه
وانه يحكم يحكم المدخل والمخرج المتعلق
بجسر الامير فبالتالي اعتقد ان ربما تكون
هناك المعارك تدور الان في ناحيه ظهري
ومحاوله دخول الدعم السريع الى هذا الامر
خاصه ان منطقه البحري هذه المنطقه يعني
بها ايضا مواقع حيويه مواقع تتبع للجيش
السوداني قباله
جسر جسر النيل الازرق حيث يعني كان توجد
هناك ايضا يعني سلاح الصيانه سلاح الاشاره
سلاح المهمات ايضا هناك مرفق يسمى المتحف
الحربي ايضا مواقع استراتيجيه لهذا الامني
والمخابرات في هذه المدخل تصب مباشره الى
شارع الانغاز ثم يمينا الى
كوبر حيث السجن العمومي في كوبر فيبدو ان
هناك انتشار في هذه المواقع للدعم السريع
من خلال هذه الاحداث المتقاعده والمعلومات
المتوفره على افضل الميدان من عدد من
المصادر وشهود عيان قالوا ان الدعم السريع
له انتشار في منطقه البحري ربما يكون هو
هل كثافه مقابل
المسلحه ما هي اهميه هذه المنطقه بحري
للدعم السريع
يحاول ان يتخذ من منطقه بحري منطقه للهجوم
ومحاوله المبادره يعني يدخل من خلال احد
الدستور الرئيسه الذي تربط منطقه بحري
بالخرطوم وهذه المنطقه تشكل موقع
استراتيجي وحجمي لان هذه هذه الجذور تقول
مباشره الى مقر القياده العامه
والى المرافق الافتراضيه سواء كانت وزاره
الدفاع او او الابراج الملحقه بها او
المجمع العسكري او مجمع السكن البرهان
بجانب القصر الرياضي حيث ان
هو يعني يعني يمكن مباشره
يوميا في القطره الجمهوري فبالتالي اعتقد
هو يحاول ان يعدل من استراتيجيته العسكريه
فيما يبدو لي من خلال الصور التي اراها
وتصاعد الدخان الابيض مما يدل على ان
المعركه ليس ملكه قويه وحاكم كما كنا
نشاهد
الدخان الاسود الكثيف الذي يحجب الرؤيه
فيبدو ان القوات المسلحه تحاول ان تستخدم
اقل قدري ممكن من القوه
منطقه البحري فيها كثافه سكانيه كبيره
خالد شكرا جزيلا لك من الختم الصحه في
خالد الفقي
المعارك مستمره والحزم لا يزال مبكرا وفقا
للعديد من المراقبين مع تحول المواجهات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الى مواجهه في مدن مفتوح زميله راويه
القاسم تعطينا لمحه عن سير المعارك في
الايام الماضيه
يعني المقبله يواصل الطرفان عملياتهما
الجيش اعلن عن استعاده مطار مروي وسلاح
المهندسين ومنشات حول مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم حيث ما تزال
قوات الدعم موجوده هناك قوات حمايه فشلت
بتحييد القواعد الجويه والمطارات الاساسيه
في البلاد خلافا لخطتها الاساسيه فبعد
اقتحامها لمطار مروي شمال السودان
واعلانها السيطره عليه عاد الاخير لقبضه
الجيش السوداني واقتصرت مكاسبها جويا على
قاعده جبل اولياء جنوب العاصمه اضافه الى
مطارين في دارفور هما مطار الفاشر شمالا
ومطار صبيره الدولي غربا فشل قوات الدعم
السريع بالسيطره على كافه القواعد الجويه
مكن الجيش من استخدام مقاتلاته لاستهداف
تمركزات وسيارات الدعم بالعاصمه تحديدا
وهي اليات غير مدرعه وهي سهله التدبير كما
ما هذا استخدام سلاح الجو الطريق امام
الجيش للسيطره على مقرات رئيسيه لقوات
الدعم السريع في محيط العاصمه
كمعسكرات سوبا جنوب الخرطوم في الطيبه
والطيبه في شمالها والصالحه ايضا وكرري في
ام درمان كما نشاهد وضمنت كذلك عدم تمكن
الدعم السريع من الحفاظ على مقراتها التي
تحتوي على احتياطيات لوجستيا في ولايتي
النيل الازرق والنيل الابيض وبورسودان
والقضارف وكسله اما نجاحات قوات الدعم
السريع فتتمثل بقطع التواصل بين شمال
العاصمه وايضا جنوبها من خلال سيطرتها على
الجسور وتعطيل حركه المرور
لقد بدات شوارع مدينه بورسودان في شمال
الشرق من السودان خاليه الى الا من بعض
الاشخاص الذين حملوا امتعتهم وفروا من
القتال الدائر بين الجيش والدعم السريه في
العاصمه الخرطوم حيث افاد شهود عيان بوجود
جثث في شهر العاصمه
الحاليه في مدينه بورسودان امنه
وقديش السوداني يسيطر لجميع قوات الدعم
السريع والامن
في البحر الاحمر
والشعب السوداني في امن
وامانسير الحركه مستمر والسوق الحمد لله
ليلا ونتمنى انه السوداني يعم الخير
والسلام
ه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات